HE'S UPWARDLY COMING,
AND HE HAD A ROCKING BOD,
AND HE'S FIGHTING
THIS DUDE MAX SCHMELING.
MAX SCHMELING
LIVED IN GERMANY.
HE WAS A GERMAN DURING THE TIME
OF THE NAZIS.
SCHMELING HAD WON
THE HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPIONSHIP
IN 1930, 'CAUSE JACK SHARKEY
HIT HIM IN THE NUTS
AND GOT DISQUALIFIED.
SO HE BASICALLY WON
THE HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPIONSHIP
OF THE WORLD
BY GETTING HIT IN THE NUTS.
JOE LOUIS' MANAGER WAS LIKE,
WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THIS EX-CHAMPION, SCHMELING,
THROW HIM IN FRONT OF LOUIS,
LOUIS WILL PUMMEL HIM.
JOE LOUIS WAS LIKE,
I DON'T NEED TO TRAIN
FOR THIS SCHMUCK, YOU KNOW?
INSTEAD OF TRAINING,
HE WAS PLAYING GOLF,
AND HE HAD ALL THESE WOMEN
COMING AROUND AND STUFF.
SO HE'S [bleep]
AND PLAYING GOLF AND STUFF
INSTEAD OF TRAINING
FOR HIS FIGHT.
MMM.
SO THE FIRST FIGHT
WAS AT YANKEE STADIUM.
THERE'S TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE THERE,
AND EVERYONE JUST ASSUMES
JOE LOUIS IS GONNA KICK
MAX SCHMELING'S BUTT.
LIKE, HITLER DIDN'T EVEN WANT IT
ADVERTISED IN GERMANY.
HITLER WAS LIKE,
THIS GUY'S GONNA LOSE.
WE DON'T WANT ANYONE
TO KNOW ABOUT THE FIGHT.
IT WAS LIKE, JOE WAS, LIKE,
DOING ALL RIGHT,
AND THEN MAX SCHMELING
JUST STARTS COMING AT HIM.
HE WAS LIKE,
BOOM, BOOM, BOOM.
AND THEN [bleep] SCHMELING
KNOCKS HIM DOWN
FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN HIS WHOLE CAREER.
JOE LOUIS WAS LIKE,
OH, [bleep].
I SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN [bleep]
AND GOLFING.
AND HE LOSES.
SO LOUIS FEELS LIKE,
I'M NOT THE REAL CHAMP
UNTIL I BEAT MAX SCHMELING,
YOU KNOW,
'CAUSE HE BEAT ME BEFORE,
SO I'M GONNA--
I'M--NOW, I WANT TO BEAT HIM,
AND SO THEY
BASICALLY ENDED UP DECIDING
THEY WERE GONNA FIGHT AGAIN.
AND, UH, YOU KNOW,
HE WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
AND ROOSEVELT SAID,
YOU KNOW,
WE NEED THESE ARMS
TO BEAT THE NAZIS.
ARE YOU GONNA WIN?
OR WHATEVER.
AND HE'S LIKE,
YEAH, I GOT TO--
I GOT TO--I--
I CAN'T DO WHAT I DID BEFORE.
I CAN'T [bleep] UP AND LOSE.
I GOT TO GET MY [bleep]
IN SHAPE.
NO WOMEN, NO GOLF.